- Everybody else has already
done text interactive stories
or adventure games.
You know what we need to do?
And I say, what?
We need to go beyond that.
We need to add graphics to it.
And I was like, oh my God, oh my God,
he's gonna do it, he's gonna do it.
- [Bold Voice] There was just one problem.
What Ken proposed had never been done.
- I love a good technical challenge
and since computers are new,
everything was new and cold.
- [Bold Voice] Games back
then came on a floppy disc.
The USB drives at their time,
but they only had about 360 K of storage.
That's just a few seconds
of a streaming song.
Forget about pictures.
- These days it would be easy.
I mean it's but it was
a different world then.
So rather than just
digitizing the pictures,
I had an idea of using the end
points of lines as graphics.
That allowed me to fit all the pictures
and a whole game on one floppy.
- "Mystery House" was the
very very first computer game
that had graphics.
It was a huge leap technologically
- [Bold Voice] The images were simple,
straightforward, nothing fancy.
But to see this on a personal
computer was a revelation.
- This is the beginning of something big.